>> CHRIS: IT'S TIME FOR:
PORTLAND FIVE-0.
PORTLAND, OREGON IS A UTOPIA FOR
LIBERAL HIPSTERS LOOKING FOR A
QUIET PLACE TO COMB THE CAT HAIR
OUT OF THEIR BEARDS WHILE SLOWLY
GOING BLIND FROM DRINKING CRAFT
MOONSHINE.
I LOVE PORTLAND.
IT'S A GREAT CITY.
BUT CRIME STILL HAPPENS, AND
WHEN IT DOES, PORTLAND KEEPS IT
WEIRD.
THE TWITTER ACCOUNT @PDXALERTS
COMPILES SOME OF THE BIZARRE
THINGS OVERHEARD ON THE POLICE
SCANNER FOR THE LAND OF FLANNEL.
FOR EXAMPLE:
"PORTLAND-POLICE RESPOND TO
NORTH EAST HANCOCK-- REPORT OF
TWO SHIRTLESS MALES IN THE ROAD
SELLING DRUGS TO A GUY THAT
LOOKS LIKE IT COULD BE WOODY
ALLEN."
WOULDN'T BE THE WORST THING HE
HAS DONE.
COMEDIANS I WANT TO YOU TELL ME
THINGS YOU WOULD HEAR ON THE
POLICE SCANNER IN PORTLAND.
JAK.
>> BACK UP, BACK UP THERE IS
GLUTEN EVERYWHERE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
SHUT THE CITY DOWN.
>>
>> OFFICER DOWN HE FELL OFF HIS
FIXE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
ANDREW.
>> OUT OF INDICA REQUESTING BACK
UP KUSH. BACK UP KUSH
I
MMEDIATELY.
>> HELP OUR ONE BLACK FRIEND WAS
MURDERED.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: ANDREW.
>> EXTRA SHOTS ORDERED.
BARISTA DOWN.
>> SUSPECT SEEN WEARING A TRUMP
FOR PRESIDENT HAT, UNIRONICALLY.
>> Chris: POINTS. THERE'S
GOTTA BE ONE GUY.
>> FIVE WHITE PEOPLE ARE TRAPPED
TOGETHER BECAUSE THEIR
DREADLOCKS GOT TIED.
>> Chris: POINTS.